[Applaus]
[Musik]
lasst mich euch eine Frage stellen
welches Land ist Chinas bester
Verbündeter und das derzeit wichtigste
Land in der geopolitischen Strategie des
asiatischen riesen ich bin mir sicher
die meisten werden sagen Nordkorea
[Musik]
und ja nordkorea ist das einzige Land
mit den China seit 1961 einem
Militärbündnis unterhält mit anderen
Worten sollte jemand China angreifen
müsste Nordkorea es mit verteidigen und
umgekehrt aber mal abgesehen von diesen
Bündnis auf dem Papier hat sich Peking
schon seit Jahren von Thymian
distanziert denn seien wir ehrlich in
Wirklichkeit hat Nordkorea seinem großen
Nachbarn außer Kopfschmerzen nicht viel
zu bieten aber das ist eine andere
Geschichte Freundschaft kann nicht
objektiv gemessen werden aber wir können
einige Zahlen finden die uns helfen zu
verstehen wie gut sich einige Länder mit
anderen verstehen eine von diesen
freundschaftskennzahlen ist der offenen
Handel stellt es euch mal folgendermaßen
vor normalerweise verkauft ein Staat nur
Waffen an Länder mit denen es gute
Beziehung fliegt Länder die sich als
verlässliche Partner erwiesen haben die
Frage lautet also wer ist eigentlich der
hauptimporteur chinesischer Waffen nun
seht euch hier oben mal die folgende
Grafik an denn sie wird euch
wahrscheinlich überraschen
[Musik]
da habt ihr es also ganz oben auf der
Liste steht Pakistan und zwar mit großen
Abstand damit ihr euch ein Bild machen
könnt 38% aller Waffen die China
zwischen 2016 und 2020 verkauft hat
gegen ihn anders islamische Land aber
wir reden nicht nur über Waffen China
ist der Gläubiger von 30 % der gesamten
Auslandsschulden Pakistans Tendenz
steigend
23 Februar 2023 Pakistans neuer 700
Millionen Dollar Kredit aus China
verschärft Ängste vor Schuldenlast der
Kredit kommt zu den 30 Milliarden Dollar
hinzu die Pakistan China bereits
schuldet China ist Pakistans größter
einzelgläubiger und verlangt im
Vergleich zu multilateralen Kreditgeber
eine relativ hohe Zinssätze im letzten
Jahr wurde das Land von verheerenden
Überschwemmungen heimgesucht die Schäden
und Produktionsausfälle in Höhe von
schätzungsweise 30 Milliarden US-Dollar
verursachten seitdem haben der Krieg in
der Ukraine der die Lebensmittel und
Treibstoffpreise in die Höhe getrieben
hat sowie jahrelange Misswirtschaft im
Land die pakistanische Wirtschaft
lahmgelegt
außerdem baut China in Pakistan einen
handelskorridor und einen Hafen diese
beiden Infrastrukturprojekte könnten für
Chinas militärisch Bestrebungen
entscheiden sein den sie entsprechend
China Strategie das zivilprojekte so
angelegt sind dass sie im Ernstfall auch
für militärische Zwecke genutzt werden
können aber dazu später mehr hinzukommt
Pakistan ist eines der instabilsten
Länder in ganz Asien wir haben hier auf
visualpolitik bereits in einem früheren
Video berichtet dass das Land am Rande
des bankords steht und das treibt nicht
nur den USA und Indien die Sorgenfalten
auf die Stirn vor allem wenn man bedenkt
dass Pakistan überhaupt Atombomben
inklusive einer schießwütigen nuklear
Doktrin verfügt und über 40
terroristische Gruppen im Land ihr
Unwesen treiben
[Musik]
ja ganz genau in Pakistan gibt es in der
Tat etwa 45 verschiedene aktive
Terrorgruppen mit anderen Worten das
islamische Land ist wie ein
Hornissennest auf einem Pulverfass um
das die Hornissen mit kleinen Fackeln
herumfliegen und gleichzeitig ist ist
ein zunehmend wichtiger Verbündeter
China ist es verwundert daher nicht dass
man in Washington ob dieser rapiden
Entwicklung immer mehr in Panik gerät
und akuten Handlungsbedarf sieht als ob
es weltweit nicht schon genug Brandherde
gäbe
25 Februar 2023 USA sind tief besorgt
dass Chinas Kredit an Pakistan als
Druckmittel eingesetzt werden könnten
während Pakistan mit einer der
schlimmsten Wirtschaftskrisen seit
Jahrzehnten zu kämpfen hat ist China
eingesprungen um den klammen Land zu
helfen china hat ein Darlehen in Höhe
von 700 Millionen US-Dollar bewegt da
der Internationale Währungsfonds seine
Entscheidung über die Gewährung eines
Kredits zu Verhinderung eines
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenbruchs im
parkistan verzögert die USA sind
zutiefst besorgt über Chinas Kredite an
Indiens Nachbarländer darunter Pakistan
und Sri Lanka diese könnten als
Druckmittel eingesetzt werden erklärte
stellvertretende Außenminister für Süd-
und Zentralasien im Vorfeld der Indien
Reise des Außenministers Anthony blinken
blinken wird am 1 märz zu einem
dreitägigen offiziellen Besuch in
Neu-Delhi eintreffen wird Islamabad nun
also zum besten Verbündeten Pekings nun
auch hier gilt wieder das ist keinen
objektiven Maßstab für Freundschaft gibt
aber Pakistan sicherlich einer der
wichtigsten Verbündeten und gleichzeitig
einer der instabilsten aber jetzt kommt
der große plus-west denn China hat einen
Plan mit dem es den Terror in Pakistan
beenden will um das 240 millionenland in
einen seiner tollsten und stabilsten
Bündnispartner zu verwandeln da stellen
sich natürlich sofort ein paar brennende
Fragen auf welche Weise soll dies Peking
überhaupt gelingen und inwiefern könnte
eine solche Entwicklung zum Problem für
den besten werden und vor allem was hat
ausgerechnet tiktok damit zu tun heute
werden all diese Fragen natürlich
beantworten und zwar gleich nach einer
kleinen werbeeinlage unseres tollen
Sponsors surfshark Dance surfshark hat
nicht nur das heutige Video möglich
gemacht nein es hat auch ein VPN im
Angebot das wirklich empfehl fährt und
vor allem sicher ist so lockt es zum
Beispiel selbstverständlich keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mit natürlich kein ein
Virtual Private Networks VPN ein nicht
vor allem gefahrenschützen die E-Mails
Lauer man muss nach wie vor um sich
walten lassen und wissen was man tut
aber stellt hier für ein Werkzeug mit
gleich mehreren Vorteilen da zum einen
erschwert ist im Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen im Netz
nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheit könnt ihr so
erhöhen z.B mit dem integrierten
klimberg das alle unerwünschten Cookies
und Popup Block weiterer Vorteil eines
dass ihr so tun könnt als während ihr an
einem anderen Ort so könnt ihr z.B auf
Webseite und Internetdienste zugreifen
die in dem Land verfügbar werden ob
daheim oder im Urlaub damit schlagt die
Zensur und blocking ein Schnäppchen
Netflix und anderes
anbieten von Europa ausnutzen oder
deutsches Internetfernsehen im Ausland
gucken mit surfshark kein Problem aber
das ist noch lange nicht alles damit nur
alles wirklich alle eure Endgeräten
registrieren Handys Notebooks oder sogar
Smart TV so und wenn ihr den Rabattcode
Politik angeht bekommt
in Höhe von 83% obendrein der ersten
drei Monate gratis dazu den Link zu
diesem Angebot findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video also
nichts wie los besorgt euch und greift
damit auch gleichzeitig uns finanziell
unter die Arme das könnt ihr übrigens
auch direkt mit Hilfe des Spenden links
den ich euch ebenfalls in die
Beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind euch
für jede Unterstützung dankbar denn
damit hätten wir uns euch in Zukunft
noch mehr und noch bessere Videos zu
liefern so und nun schnell wieder zu
unseren heißen fragen wie will Peking
den Terror im Pakistan bekämpfen und
könnte eine solche Entwicklung ein
Problem für den besten darstellen wie so
oft werden wir zur Beantwortung dieser
Fragen zunächst einen kurzen Blick in
die Geschichte werfen also aufgepasst
[Musik]
wer mit dem Feuer spielt darf sich nicht
wundern wenn sein Haus abbereimt
bei Pakistan handelt es sich um eines
der sieben Starts also der Länder deren
Name auf Stand endet Stan heißt dabei je
nach sprachherkunft in etwa so viel wie
Ort Heimat oder Staat zum Beispiel
bedeutet Kasachstan übersetzt in etwa
Heimat bzw Staat der Sachen man würde
gemäß dieses Schemas also annehmen dass
Pakistan das Land einer entsprechend
benannten Volksgruppe sei doch dem ist
nicht so man könnte höchstens die Wörter
Pack und Stan einzeln aus dem Persischen
übersetzen was dann in etwa Land der
reinen ergeben würde das aber ist nicht
die gängige Interpretation des
staatsnames denn auch wenn es nicht so
aussieht Pakistan ein Akronym die Name
die auf dem Bildschirm sieht sind die
wichtigsten ethnischen Gruppen die in
Pakistan Leben P für Punjabi a für
Afghanen für Kaschmiri ist für Cindy und
tarn für die lutschen die blutchen ja
dann ja okay ich weiß es handelt sich
nicht um ein perfektes Akronym aber Park
ist krank wirklich noch komischer die
Endung aufs tarn Pasta dagegen gut in
der Region auf jeden Fall ist der Name
Pakistan sehr bedeutsam wenn wir seine
Geschichte betrachten und dafür müssen
wir weit in die Vergangenheit
zurückgehen noch bevor die Briten in der
Region ankamen
[Musik]
das was wir heute als Pakistan kennen
war einst unter mehreren verschiedenen
ethnischen Gruppen aufgeteilt mit
anderen Worten es gab unter den Menschen
dort kein Gefühl der Zugehörigkeit zu
einer Nation namens Pakistan es handelte
sich um ein Gebiet das von verschiedenen
ethischen Gruppen bevölkert wurde die
nur wenig miteinander gemeint hatten die
größte Gruppe bildeten die Punjabi und
die der paar Stunden sind dies saraikis
oder blutchen waren viel viel kleiner
jede dieser ethnischen Gruppen sprach
auch eine andere Sprache doch plötzlich
kamen die Briten und kolonisierten den
indischen zu Kontinent das gesamte
Gebietes heutigen Pakistans Indiens
Bangladesch und mehr am Mars ein
gigantisches Mosaik aus verschiedenen
Kulturen und mitnehmen nach längerer
Zeit als Teil von britisch Indien wurde
diese Direktorin jedoch im Jahr 1947 als
Indien und Pakistan unabhängig wurde mal
das heutige war schon vorher aus der
Kolonie ausgegliedert worden und wurde
ein Jahr später unabhängig und ihr
werdet euch vielleicht fragen moment mal
was ist eigentlich mit Bangladesch nun
nach der Unabhängigkeit von den dritten
wurde britisch Indien grob gesprochen in
einen mehrheitlichen hinduistischen
Staat und einen mehrheitlich
muslimischen Staat aufgeteilt in Indien
und Pakistan und das Gebiet des heutigen
Bangladesch gehörte zu Pakistan und zwar
obwohl es auf der anderen Seite von
Indien liegt und damit keine
Landverbindung zum restpakistans hatte
die gemeinsame Religion erwies sich
schließlich auch als nicht ausreichend
um die zwei ethnisch und kulturell
unterschiedlichen Gebiete
zusammenzuhalten die Unterdrückung der
Bangladesch ist durch West Pakistan für
den 1971 zu einer Revolution und einem
kurzen aber sehr blutigen Bürgerkrieg
und in dem schaffte es dann gleich sich
mit militärische Hilfe Indiens die
Unabhängigkeit von westpakistan zu
erkämpfen der Prozess aus einer Region
in der verschiedenen zusammengeschoben
wurden ein Nationalstaat zu schaffen ist
nun mal sehr schwierig und verläuft
nicht immer erfolgreich wie das traurige
Beispiel waren echt zeigt doch auch das
verbliebene pakistan hat seine massiven
ethnischen und religiösen Spannungen nie
überwunden und zwar intern wie extern
bis heute gibt es kein Konflikte
zwischen Pakistan und Indien wobei beide
Länder über Atomwaffen verfügen und
nicht ahnen was ich viele von euch
fragen warum versteht sich Pakistan so
schlecht mit Indien
nun hauptsächlich wegen eines weiteren
religiös ethnischen Konflikts in diesem
Fall geht es um die Region Kaschmir als
das britische Empire in dem Gebiet ankam
beschloss ist die Macht in Kaschmir an
eine hinduistische minderheitsübergeben
die druckergras diese Gruppe führte
ethnische Säuberung gegen die Muslime
durch die in Kaschmir vorher an der
Macht waren und wenn man bedenkt dass
95% der Bevölkerung Moslems waren kann
man sich vorstellen dass sie darüber
nicht gerade erfreut waren der
Wendepunkt kam jedoch mit der
Unabhängigkeit Indiens und Pakistans im
Jahr 1947 Park gestern beansprucht die
Bergregion für sich drüber von Kaschmir
entschied sich stattdessen für die
Eingliederung in die Republik Indien
seitdem liegen sich die beiden Länder in
den Haaren oder besser in einem
Permanent wählenden Grenzkonflikt
aber wartet ein Moment denn das ist nur
eine der vielen Konflikte die Pakistan
belasten die Spannungen zwischen den
verschiedenen ethnischen Gruppen aus
denen sich das Land zusammensetzt haben
nie aufgehört und aus welchen Gründen
fragt ihr euch vielleicht ist er eine
religiöse Frage oder eine Frage der mir
nun wieder noch der Hauptgrund ist
wirtschaftlicher Natur oder besser
gesagt es geht um die ungleiche
Verteilung staatlicher nutzen
[Musik]
in Pakistan werden die staatlichen
Mittel an die verschiedenen Provinzen
verteilt je nachdem wie viele Menschen
in der jeweiligen Provinz leben wenn wir
bedenken dass in der Provinz punschab
etwa 110 Millionen Menschen leben und
Pakistan einer Gesamtbevölkerung von 220
Millionen hat fließt natürlich die
Hälfte aller Gelder in dieser Region
wenn wir jedoch die Tatsache
berücksichtigen dass die punjabis die
Mehrheit im Parlament stellen und damit
natürlich versuchen die Interessen ihre
Region und ihre ethnischen Gruppe zu
vertreten haben wir den perfekten
Cocktail für einen ethnischen Konflikt
[Musik]
beschweren sich permanent dass sie zu
wenig Mittel erhalten die paar Stunden
die in dieser Region leben beklagen sich
ebenfalls dass sie materiell zu kurz
kommen aber die meisten vernachlässigte
Region ist zweifellos belugees daran im
Südwesten des Landes Belus dann ist die
flächenmäßig größte Region des Landes
mit der längsten Küstenlinie aber nur 5%
der Bevölkerung leben hier aus diesem
Grund ist es auch die Region die am
wenigsten staatliche Mittel erhält die
hier lebenden bunjabis haben sich viel
Land angeeignet das früher den
Belutschen gehört hatte mehr noch von
der Hauptstadt Islamabad aus haben sie
mit eiserner Faust in die regionale
Politik eingegriffen und deshalb wurde
im Jahr 2000 eine Terrorgruppe ins Leben
gerufen die belochisten liberation Armee
also die Volksbefreiungsarmee von
belugestern seitdem sind Nachrichten wie
die folgende an der Tagesordnung die
Befreiungsarmee von der kennt sich zum
Anschlag in Karachi und zur ersten
selbstporträterin die explosions einen
Lieferwagen in der Universität von
Karachi im Süden Pakistans die Bela
erklärte den Anschlag sei von einer
selbstmordatentäterin verübt worden ganz
genau all diese ethnischen Konflikte
haben eine ellenlange Liste an
terroristischen Gruppen hervorgebracht
als ob das noch nicht genug wäre hat das
pakistanische Militär selbst viele
dieser Gruppen unterstützt aber welches
Interesse könnte die Armee eines Landes
daran haben terroristische Gruppen im
eigenen Land zu unterstützen nun die
Antwort liegt in Indien Pakistans
Erzfeind die pakistanische Armee hat
eine sehr merkwürdige Strategie um das
verhasste Nachbarland zu bekämpfen diese
Strategie hat aber einen sehr
anschaulichen Namen Indien mit tausend
Schnitten
sie besteht darin Aufständischen
gruppeninhalt Indien zu unterstützen um
das Land zu destabilisieren muss toll
sein so eine Nachbarn zu haben nicht
wahr und seitdem gibt es Dutzende von
Terrorgruppen mit für die meisten
Europäer und ausreichlichen Namen
alleine im Kaschmir operieren zum
Beispiel laskari taiba hasip ultra
hygien und ja ich el Muhammad Lackierer
ist beispielsweise für einige der
größten Terroranschläge in Indien
verantwortlich darunter der große
Bombenanschlag in Mumbai 2008 bei den
160 Menschen getötet worden
aber diese tolle Strategie hat einen
kleinen Haken sie gießt nämlich Öl in
ein Feuer das am Ende alle Akteure
verbrennen wird Terrorismus ist nun mal
eine der dümmsten politischen Strategien
die ein Land verfolgen kann schauen wir
uns mal die Zahlen an die Finanzierung
von Terrorgruppen ist ein extrem
zweischneidiges Schwert Pakistan ist
heute ein Hornissennest mit Dutzenden
von bewaffneten Gruppen und zahlreichen
zivilen Opfern und wir reden ja nicht
nur über einen Sicherheitsproblem
tatsächlich ist Terrorismus auch ein
wirtschaftliches Problem ich meine
logisch wer will schon ein Unternehmen
in ein Land Gründen in jedem Moment eine
Bombe hochgehen kann wir haben bereits
in früheren Videos über die
pakistanische Wirtschaft gesprochen
jetzt werden wir über einen weiteren
wichtigen Akteur in der Entwicklung des
pakistanischen Terrorismus sprechen und
ihr werdet euch fragen von wem wurde die
Rede ist nun von niemand anderen als den
US Open ganz genau aber welches
Interesse hätte Washington an der
Finanzierung von Terrorgruppen in
Pakistan nur das werden wir uns jetzt
ansehen
[Musik]
das Vermächtnis von John Rambo
diejenigen unter euch die in ihren 30ern
sind werden sich noch an die Rambo Filme
erinnern oder und ich bin mir sicher
dass viele von euch Rambo 3 gesehen
haben nun zwischen all den Explosionen
in diesem Film geht es um viel mehr
Geopolitik als er vielleicht denkt in
diesem Film trainiert John Rambo
gespielt von Sylvester Stallone die
Mutter hat ihn Krieger die in
Afghanistan gegen die gottloses so wird
Union kämpfen und zwar direkt an der
Grenze zu Pakistan es waren die 1980er
Jahre in den Jahren waren die
Kommunisten die Bösewichte im Film und
alle die sich gegen sie erhoben waren
automatisch die Helden und ja dazu
gehörten auch jene Helden der Freiheit
die in den Bergen Afghanistans ihre
Jahrhunderte alten Traditionen
verteidigten nun dieser Film spiegelt
eine Ereignis wieder dass ich
tatsächlich zugetragen hat während des
Kalten Krieges verbündete sich das
strenge religiöse Pakistan mit den USA
im Kampf gegen die gottloses und wird
Union so wurde Washington zum größten
Waffenlieferanten Pakistans und zum
Ausbilder von Terroristen um euch eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben bis 1965
importierte Pakistan 70% Waffen von
Uncle Sam danach verschlechterten sich
die Beziehungen zwischen den beiden
Ländern jedoch zu Sehens 1965 verhängte
Washington ein Waffen Embargo gegen
Indien und Pakistan und als Pakistan mit
seinem Atomprogramm begann blockierten
die USA immer mehr Waffenlieferungen
zu Beginn des neuen Jahrtausends
erschienen ist jedoch so als sei die
Freundschaft zwischen diesen beiden
Ländern auf einen Weg der Besserung nach
dem Anschlägen von 11 September
erklärten die Vereinigten Staaten den
Krieg gegen den Terror Osama bin Laden
war der meistgesuchte Mann der Welt und
weil sie glaubten dass er sich in
Afghanistan versteckt hielten die USA
Pakistan um Hilfe im Gegenzug hoben sie
handelssanktion auf leisteten direkte
Wirtschaftshilfe und vieles mehr man
könnte meines Pakistan am Ende die Nase
voll hatte aber irgendwie hat meine
islamabatte nie damit aufgehört sich
über US Flugzeuge zu spielen die den
Luftraum des Landes verletzten überlegt
mal die Amerikaner waren auf der Suche
nach Osama Bin an und was die Beziehung
zwischen diesen beiden Ländern
letztendlich zurückgebracht genau der
Moment als den Laden gefunden wurde wie
ihr euch vielleicht erinnert hatte sich
bin Laden Stunde in einer der reichsten
Städte Pakistans versteckt abotterbad
genauer gesagt liegt er dort in einer
gut gesicherten Villa und zwar schon
seit Jahren aber wie ist es möglich dass
die pakistanische Armee das nicht
bemerkt hat erst recht wo sich gar nicht
weit von seiner Villa entfernt ein
pakistanischer Militärkomplex befand ist
es möglich dass die Pakistani da
vielleicht ein paar Augen zu gedrückt
haben wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt hat
sich die Romanze zwischen den USA und
Pakistan nach dieser Sache ziemlich
abgekühlt und zwar aus guten Grund denn
machen wir uns nichts vor der Verkauf
von Waffen in dieses Land wurde
erheblich reduziert aber hatte Pakistan
damit etwa niemanden mehr von dem es
Waffen kaufen konnte nur wenn uns das
Leben eines Lehrer dann folgendes wenn
sich eine Tür schließt öffnet sich
dadurch vielleicht ein Fenster
20 Oktober 2022 China blockiert
weiterhin die Aufnahme von Terroristen
aus Pakistan auf die schwarze Liste
china hat gestern erneut die Bemühungen
Indiens und der USA verhindert hat den
Sohn von
lascherid bei den Ver Präsentationen auf
die schwarze Liste zu setzen es
bekräftigte damit seine frühere Position
Sanktionen gegen Terroristen aus
Pakistans und blockieren im April hatte
Indien den Sohn von said zum Terroristen
erklärt in einer Mitteilung hieß es
hafistalexaid sei an der Rekrutierung
der Finanzierung der Planung und der
Durchführung von Anschlägen der laschka
alta IVA in Indien und Afghanistan
beteiligt in diesem Fall haben die
Vereinigten Staaten die Tür zu Pakistan
geschlossen aber genau das hat China ein
fester ganz neuer Möglichkeiten geöffnet
und die Geschichte die die Chinesen den
Pakistan ist da erzählen klingt fast wie
aus einem Hollywood Filme also
aufgepasst denn jetzt wird's erst so
richtig spannend
tiktok Schnüffler gegen Terror
im April 2015 besuchte der chinesische
präsidentischen Pakistan zum ersten Mal
in seiner Funktion als Staatsoberhaupt
seine Worte vor dem Besuch des
Verbündeten Landes den besten Freund des
chinesischen riesen machten deutlich wie
China über Pakistan denkt plötzlich an
als ich jung war hörte ich viele hörende
Geschichten über Pakistan und die
Freundschaft zwischen unseren beiden
Ländern um nur einige zu nennen ich
hörte davon wie das pakistanische Volk
danach strebte sein schönes Land
aufzubauen und ich Pakistan einen
luftkorrektur für China öffnete um die
Welt zu erreichen und China dabei
unterstützte seinen rechtmäßigen Sitz in
den Vereinten Nationen wieder zu
erlangen diese Geschichten haben einen
tiefen Eindruck bei mir hinterlassen ich
freue mich auf meine bevorstehenden
Staatsbesuch in Pakistan im Jahr 2015
die Beziehungen zwischen den Chinesen
und der Regionen die wir heute Pakistan
nennen reichen natürlich bis in die Zeit
vor der britischen Kolonialzeit in
Südasien zurück doch die wahre
Freundschaft zwischen China und Pakistan
begann erst nachdem beide Länder in
ihrer heutigen Form unabhängig geworden
waren
Pakistan war nämlich eines der ersten
Länder welches das kommunistische China
als Nation anerkannte außerdem
akzeptierte es die von China
vorgeschlagenen Grenzziehung zu chinchan
und als ob das noch nicht genug wäre hat
China Pakistan in seinen Kriegen gegen
Indien unterstützt einem Antagonisten
beider Länder gemeinsame Feinde machen
nun mal Freunde erinnert ihr euch noch
daran wie wir euch erzählt haben dass
sie Vereinigten Staaten 1965 ihre
Waffenlieferungen ein Pakistan gekauft
haben nun China behalte sich damals
diese Lücke zu füllen und zwischen 1965
und 73 kamen 60% aller von Pakistan
importierten Waffen aus China und obwohl
diese 60% heute nicht mehr aufrecht
erhalten werden kommen immer noch 40
Prozent aller Waffen die Pakistan
importiert aus dem Reich der Mitte die
Liste an der Rüstungsgütern ist dabei
ziemlich vollständig vp4 Panzer
unbemannte Jagdflugzeuge ubote JF 17
Kampfflugzeuge keine halben Sachen also
und die beiden Staaten Handeln nicht nur
mit Waffen sondern eigentlich mit allem
Pakistan ist Teil von Chinas neuer
Seitenstraße und Peking hat beschlossen
sein
Verbündeten mit dem Kronjuwel dieser
Initiative zu belohnen
[Musik]
im Jahr 2015 haben hier und Pakistan
einen wirtschaftskorridor eingerichtet
der die beiden Länder verbindet China
nutzt die privilegierte geographische
Lage Pakistans mit seiner Küste am
Indischen Ozean die an die arabische
Welt und insbesondere einen ehrengrenzt
es sieht in Pakistan eine große
geopolitische Chance seine
Vorzeigeprojekt dreht sich dabei um eine
bestimmte Küstenstadt die Stadt gewartet
wir haben hier bereits über diese Stadt
und ihre Bedeutung für China gesprochen
aber es lohnt sich die Fakten noch
einmal zusammenzufassen aber da liegt im
Süden Pakistans in der Provinz Beluga
seine Nähe zur Straße von muss macht es
zu einem perfekten Ort für den Bau eines
Hafens der alle Arten von Produkten
insbesondere natürlich Erdöl aufnehmen
kann bedenkt bitte dass das Öl das china
kauft durch indischen Hoheit Gewässer
transportiert werden muss im Falle eines
Konfliktes könnte Indien im gesamten
Verkehr stoppen und China innerhalb
weniger Monate zu Fall bringen der Hafen
ist daher das Kernstück um dass ich
andere Projekte in der Stadt drehen wie
der Bau eines Krankenhauses
Wellenbrecher oder der nächste große
Schritt der Bau einer Ölpipeline einer
Ölpipeline die war da mit China
verbindet und durch ganz Pakistan von
Norden nach Süden verlaufen soll
aber nicht so schnell wo haben wir noch
mal gesagt dass diese Stadt liegt in
blue System dieser unruhigen Region in
der die belugestern Liberation Army
ihren Sitz hat dieser der Gruppe die im
April letzten Jahres bei einem Anschlag
drei chinesische Staatsbürger getötet
hat
pakistanische selbstmordatentäterin
nimmt chinesische Lehrer ins Visier eine
militante pakistanische Gruppe erklärte
sie habe die Attentäterin speziell auf
Chinesen angesetzt in Anschlag im
vergangenen Juli musste Pakistan Peking
eine Entschädigung zahlen die
Befreiungsarmee von Blue chestan eine
militante Separatistengruppe die sich
gegen chinesische Investitionen in
Pakistan wendet hat sich zu den
Anschlägen bekannt und erklärt sie habe
die Attentäterin gezielt auf Chinesen
angesetzt die Separatisten behaupten
dass sowohl Peking als auch die
pakistanische Regierung mit den
handelskorrekturprojekten die Ressourcen
beluge Distanz ausbeuten
[Musik]
tja es sieht ganz so aus dass auch China
sich nicht nur die Rosinen aus dem
Kuchen picken kann nein Pickings Pläne
werden von Pakistans Terrorismus Kultur
genauso bedroht wie die der anderen
Mächte die sich um das Land bemühten was
gedenkt das Reich der Mitte also zu tun
nun meine Lieben visualpolitik Zuschauer
china hat den Terrorismus im Land nicht
aus den Augen verloren zwar sind mehrere
finanzpakete die ist da Pakistan
schickte an die Verbesserung der
Wirtschaft geknüpft aber andere Projekte
sind konkret an die Verbesserung der
Sicherheit gebunden denn aufgrund
mangeln der Sicherheit konnten die
chinesischen Projekte in Pakistan nicht
zu Vorankommen wie sie sollten die
Chinesen forderten sogar die Abriegelung
der gesamten Stadt war da und wenn wir
auf die vielen Sicherheitsprobleme noch
Pakistans marode Wirtschaft drauf packen
die am Rande des Zusammenbruch steht und
nicht in der Lage ist ihre Schulden zu
bezahlen haben sie ein sehr riskantes
Szenario für China das Pakistan nicht
der Ponyhof sein wird den Sie erwartet
haben scheinen nun auch die Chinesen
begriffen zu haben und sie haben sich
deswegen entschlossen in Sachen
Terrorbekämpfung Liebe zu klotzenden
pakistanischen militanten auf die
schwarze Liste nach den China seine
Blockadehaltung aufgegeben hat China
verteidigte am Dienstag seine
Entscheidung den Vereinten Nationen zu
erlauben einen gegen Indien gerichteten
militanten Anführer als globalen
Terroristen zu designieren und sagte
dass diese Maßnahme die internationale
Zusammenarbeit gegen den Terrorismus
verbessern würde Terrorismus ist eine
gemeinsame Geißel der Menschheit sagte
der Sprecher des chinesischen
Außenministeriums waren dann bin auf
einer Pressekonferenz in Peking als er
auf Chinas Rückzieher angesprochen wurde
aha es geht also doch eh King scheint
nun also nicht nur mit den USA und in
den an einer Leine ziehen zu wollen nein
es möchte auch selbst aktiv an der
Terrorbekämpfung in Pakistan mitwirken
und zwar auf eine ganz besondere Weise
die uns alle aufhorchen lassen sollte
China und Pakistan arbeiten nach dem
Selbstmordattentat gemeinsam an der
Untersuchung ein Team von chinesischen
Sicherheitsbeamten reiste nach Pakistan
um die Ermittlungen zu unterstützen so
dass Innenministerium ein Zeichen für
die Ernsthaftigkeit die Peking den
Anschlag beides ist die chinesischen
Beamten unterstützten die pakistanischen
anti-trauerkräfte unter anderem bei der
Auswertung von Überwachungskameras und
Daten aus Mobiltelefonen so dass
Ministerium die Hinweise die sich fanden
den pakistanischen Behörden den
Hauptverdächtigen des Anschlags auf die
Universität aufzuspüren der im Juli
verhaftet wurde ganz genau die
massenüberwachung der ganzen Bevölkerung
ist eben etwas womit sich die Chinesen
bestens auskennen und jetzt haltet euch
fest so wie es aussieht verfügt Peking
in Pakistan mittlerweile auch über die
beste Datenbasis aller Geheimdienste
denn die Kommunikation von mindestens
der Hälfte aller pakistanisiert wird
durch tiktok überwacht mit 39 Millionen
Download behauptete tiktok auch im
vergangenen Jahr seine Vormachtstellung
gegenüber Facebook das um mehr als 7
Millionen Downloads hinterherhinkte und
dass die Chinesen Pakistan mit ihrer
verkappten Spionage App besonders stark
penetrieren konnten hat besonderen Grund
in Pakistan habe ich festgestellt dass
diese Plattform bei der Arbeiterklasse
Anklang findet 70% unserer Bevölkerung
lebt in ländlichen Gebieten und viele
von ihnen können nicht lesen und
schreiben aber sie können Ihre Emotionen
Gefühle und ihr Talent darstellen das
ist es was tiktok ihnen bietet sie
müssen nicht Englisch lesen oder
schreiben sie können sein wer sie sind
in ihrer Sprache und in ihrer Herkunft
wir können beobachten dass jemand aus
einem beliebigen Dorf der in seinem
Umfeld arbeitet zum Beispiel als
Hausmädchen aufgrund seiner Inhalte
Anerkennung findet der Konsum und den
Nutzer der Plattform also Nieren
miteinander weshalb diese Plattform auch
für berufliche Telefonate praktisch ist
negert Aktivist für digitale Rechte es
ist klar das Pakistan seine stärkste
Rettungsleine in China findet und das
China Pakistan als einen seiner besten
Freunde sieht wenn nicht sogar als den
besten von der frühen gegenseitigen
Anerkennung bis hin zu den militärischen
und wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen das ist
der Grund warum China so stark auf
Pakistan setzt obwohl das Land weltweit
mit das feindlichste Investitionsklima
überhaupt aufweist ihr seht also wir
alle müssen Pak kann wahrscheinlich noch
lange im Auge behalten unser nächstes
Video zu diesem Brand heißen Thema ist
also bereits vorprogrammiert vergesst
daher bitte nicht das Abo plus Glöckchen
um es nicht zu verpassen und bis dahin
könnt ihr ein paar der Prinzen Fragen im
Kommentarbereich diskutieren könnte ich
Ihnen den Terrorismus in Pakistan
wirklich zum Verschwinden bringen wird
es Pakistan gelingen seinen Spiel mit
China zu verbessern wird die ungleiche
Freundschaft zwischen den beiden Ländern
von Dauer sein oder wird es den besten
vielleicht doch gelingen Pakistan erneut
zur Verfügung haut in die Tasten wenn
wir immer sind wir auf eure Diskussion
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch was dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Like und
teilt es auch mit euren Freunden aber
diese auch mitreden können natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch mit diesem Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung oder in dem Video
mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]